what we're going to do in this video is
start to think about voting behavior and
in particular we're going to start
classifying motivations for why someone
votes for a particular candidate and I'm
going to introduce some terms that you
that will impress your political science
friends but you'll see that they map to
things that we see every day or even
behaviors that we see in ourselves in a
pretty intuitive way
so one pretty clear reason why someone
might vote for one candidate or another
is because of their political party and
so this would be referred to as party
line voting party line voting so if your
family has always been a Republican and
you're a Republican and you just always
support the Republican candidate that
would be party line voting now another
behavior that political scientists will
often talk about is the idea of rational
choice a rational choice and this is the
idea that someone would choose to vote
for one candidate or another based on a
perception of which candidate is going
to benefit them the most which one would
it be rational for their own well-being
so for example if you said hey you know
what
I really care about the corporate tax
rate I'm the CEO of a corporation if my
corporate tax rate were to go down then
I would be able to have a more thriving
business and I think one candidate is
going to do better for me that on the
corporate tax rate and I'm gonna vote
for them because of that that would be
your rational choice your model your
what's driving your voting behaviors
what's gonna benefit me now another
classification that you will hear talked
about is retrospective voting
retrospective and this is the idea that
hey I'm just gonna vote for someone if
it seems like they've been doing a good
job or if it seems like things have been
improving under their watch you're
looking in retrospect and this will
often be for incumbents and saying hey
look yeah the last term was pretty good
with them so I'm gonna vote for them
again now the last classification we
will introduce in this video is the
opposite of retrospective voting and
this is looking into the future
prospective voting prospective voting
and here you might look at one candidate
and say look I think that they will be
better for the country over the next
four years
you're not even necessarily thinking
about your own personal benefit you're
thinking about the country as a whole
but you're looking forward you're
looking prospectively and thinking about
hey a candidate a I think is gonna do a
better job so I'm gonna vote for her
so with these classifications out of the
way let's look at some statements that
you might hear from folks when they
think about who they are voting for so
here it says the economy has been
growing under Clinton so he has my vote
so pause this video and how would you
classify this motivation for voting well
here the person the voter is talking
about the economy in the recent past so
this right over here is retrospective
voting so I'll draw a line right over
there that is retrospective voting
Clinton seems to have been doing a good
job where the economy's who've been
going under him so he has my he has my
vote now what about this statement I am
a lifelong Democrat so Obama has my vote
pause this video what type of voting
behavior is that well here the
individual is clearly motivated by their
party line they're not talking about
Obama being good for them in particular
they're not talking about what Obama's
gonna do in the future or what he's done
in the recent past they're just talking
about his party and that being the
motivation for voting for him
so that would be party line voting now
what about this statement Bush has ideas
that will be really good for this
country so I'm going to vote for him
pause this video what type of voting
behavior is that well here the voters
thinking prospectively thinking about
well what will Bush do for the country
in the near future ideas that will be
really good for this country so that is
prospective voting and then one more
sample so if someone were to say I think
Mitt Romney will lower my taxes so I'm
going to vote for him
what would that be pause the video again
well we have one choice left here and
that is indeed rational choice this
voter is voting based on what is going
to benefit them Mitt Romney's going to
lower their taxes so they're gonna vote
for them and to be clear it's not that
everyone's behavior Falls clearly into
one of these categories it oftentimes
will be a mix of these categories in
fact oftentimes someone might say hey I
like Obama cuz he's a Democrat and I
think he's going to be good for me and
things might have been good under him or
the perception is that things are good
under him and they might believe that
it's going to be good going forward many
voters will be motivated by a
combination of these